hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory super
brief video but I want to share with you
all that the proposed Harry Potter TV
show on HBO has finally been confirmed
two hours ago a teaser video was posted
on the HBO max official Twitter
including the words your Hogwarts letter
is here Max has ordered the first ever
hashtag Harry Potter scripted television
series a faithful adaptation of the
iconic books hashtag stream on Max there
are currently zero details to what the
show will entail who will star in it and
who is making it but we do know that
it's currently planned as a decade-long
series with a new cast each season will
be authentic to the original books and
bring Harry Potter and these incredible
Adventures to new audiences around the
world while the Original Classic and
beloved films will remain at the core of
the franchise and available to watch
globally we are delighted to give
audiences the opportunity to discover
Hogwarts in a whole new way says HBO CEO
Casey bloys in a statement Harry Potter
is a cultural phenomenon and it is clear
there is such an enduring love and
thirst for The Wizarding World I'll be
sure to keep you posted with more
updates on the channel as time
progresses I will likely start
investigating in piecing information
together to see if there's more out
there until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
foreign
[Music]